[Music]
I know that there is a lot of sexual
harassment racism and so on in our lives
and I don't doubt that the majority of
people who promote political correctness
minute sincerely I am NOT saying that I
am NOT saying in the way of right-wing
paranoia that they are evil people who
want to destroy American Way of life I'm
just saying this that the way they
approach the problem is that instead of
resolving it
the predominant effect is just to keep
it under track and allowing the true
problem racism sexism to survive in a
more covered up version and so on and so
on
for example I always like this extreme
example let's take racist jokes yes they
function in a racist way but for me the
true overcoming of racism is not that
you prohibit racist drugs but that you
establish a social not just and not even
only social change new society but even
such a change of atmosphere that you can
tell exactly the same jokes without
appearing racist when you are simply in
a true relationship of equality respect
and so on sometimes dirty jokes even
gently racist jokes done in a non racist
way by this I mean that you include
yourself in you make fun of yourself and
so on
they are incredible I think your
American term is icebreakers you know
because it's easy to be a non racist in
this political correct way who I respect
your your your your your food your
national dances no when does it happen
a real contact with another I claim it's
very difficult to arrive at it without a
small exchange of an opportunity it were
in a wonderful way so I claim Rey for me
an ideal post-race situation is let's
say I am an Indian interior an
african-american we are telling all the
time dirty jokes to each other about
each other about ourselves but in such a
way that we just laugh and the more we
are telling them the more we are friends
I mean why because in this way we really
resolve the tension of racism what I'm
afraid with without coming back to our
question with political correctness is
that it's a desperate reaction they know
they cannot solve the real problem so
they escape into controlling how we
speak about it and by real problem I
don't mean in a primitive way just
economic redistribution and so on but
even the symbolic fact of actual social
relationship and so on you know what
should politically correct people learn
British customs why because British and
Japanese different countries but there
are two of the countries which are mega
masters in how to reproduce all the
brutality of domination despising the
other but without being offensive with
an utmost nice speech elegance and so on
you know the that's the miracle of truly
successful racism that you reproduce all
the prejudices but with a very soft
voice apparently respecting the other
and so on and so on
so again org what also bothers me with
political correctness or discolor ins of
the other is that a tolerance is a false
notion today always like this example I
always to my students when they claim
over to if you are against tolerance
what are you for brutal racism no I tell
them okay there is one guy who did quite
a lot against racism Martin Luther King
look at his speech
he never even mentions the world
tolerance if I checked it up you can
download his speech if you were to tell
him that we need more we white people
need to be more tolerant towards the
black people he would have lost probably
No so this is a very suspicious idea
that this translation of domination of
racism and so on into terms of tolerance
no tolerance is a a very ambiguous term
quite often tolerance can even work as
its own opposite in what sense
look if you take a typical upper middle
class American I would like to put him
on her I saw them together with a real
low-class african-american or white guy
I can guarantee you they would be
horrified with all the dirty joke
vulgarities and so on and for them they
would have been very intolerant towards
him so for me there is always in
Tolerance something off let's keep the
other in the pharisee she they it
disturbs me at the proper distance don't
allow them to come too close to me
tolerance often means intolerance for
the actual other they accept the other
in the forest it is the the purified
other like for example for politically
correct people Native Americans whatever
you call them I don't want to call them
that do you know my old rock which is
true I met some Native American
so-called
University people who told me they said
the term Native Americans why because it
has this uncanny opposition sorry
uncanny some to natural culture we are
native and what are you then cultural
Americans what they told me we much
prefer to be called Indians at least our
name
the monument white man stupidity who
thought they are in need India where
they are here so I I love this as they
are so fanatically suspicious and they
about this false patronizing appraisal
of the white liberals like you know we
usually say we brutally exploit nature
mining and so on but Native Americans do
it differently they talk to mountains
they have this more organic dialogic
approach and so on and so on they said
this so much they one of them even so
brutally told me I love this this is
true he gave me I forgot his name
I'm very sorry a short text he wrote
where she demonstrates through
statistics I don't know if it's true
let's say he tries to demonstrate that
Native American so-called Indians killed
more buffaloes and burned more forests
than all white people together what was
his point his point was precisely don't
idealize us you are patronizing us by
making as this politically correct to
people who are holistic blah blah blah
no please we can also be evil we can
also be horrible and so on and so on you
see the same problem is with refugees in
Europe intelligent Native Americans are
terribly sensitive against this against
the oppressive other side of this
politically correct way of Native
Americans have some ancient wisdom
holistic approach and so on and so on I
mean that's why I'm sorry for a bit and
all sorry of mine but that's why I think
here Lee admire
Malcolm X you know why what does it mean
epps it means of course we don't have
family name we black slaves were torn
out deprived of our roots and like
family links and so on when they were
kidnapped from Africa and so on but
what's his genius his way is not the way
of the cupid hollywood bestseller dream
failure who
the truth whoo let's find our roots now
his ideals what if this axe it means we
have no roots we are deprived of roots
what if this gives us a new freedom to
establish a new more universal community
than that of white people it's an
ingenious idea of think what appears and
is a terrible trauma being deprived of
your roots you have no proper tradition
family tradition and so on is the new
trends of freedom
[Music]